we begin in south korea today where a
recent report by an independent
commission has blamed past governments
for atrocities committed in a
state-supported institution the
commission has asked for an official
apology from the government
more than 600 people were killed and
hundreds of others raped beaten tortured
and enslaved in brothers home a facility
for so-called vagrants in busan city
most of these were
children it operated in the 70s and 80s
under military governments which wanted
to beautify the streets particularly
before the 1988 seoul olympics
homeless people and children were picked
up off the street sometimes by police
officers and taken to brother's home
where they were kept at the mercy of
older inmates and guards
many of those taken weren't even
homeless
they were for lack of a better word
kidnapped and thrown into a system of
state supported imprisonment
hanjong's son was nine years old when he
was brought to brother's home a welfare
center in busan because of his short
stature he stood at the front of his row
of children directly witnessed to the
abuse often inflicted by other residents
who had risen to positions of authority
the squad leader raised his club to beat
the boy again when he had another
seizure
the club hit him right in the head with
a crack as he fell down
blood poured from the head and there was
a horrible smell
his body shook all over
the blood spread like water as he
collapsed his pupils were totally
dilated
did not see the boy again for over a
decade han has campaigned for the truth
now he's working on a replica of
brother's home to shed more light on
what happened there
investigators now say 657 people died at
the facility last month south korea's
truth and reconciliation commission
confirmed evidence of slavery rape and
murder at brother's home in the 1970s
and 80s that impacted tens of thousands
it was confirmed that the human dignity
of the detainees at brother's home was
violated in various ways including
forced labor assault abuse sexual
violence and death
and it was confirmed that the government
did not fulfill its duty to manage and
oversee brother's home
han recounts repeated sexual abuse
the big bullies didn't have to share
their beds
so they had lots of space
space they used to sexually assault the
pretty looking ones they picked up
during their free time
if they didn't comply
they dragged the boys to the washroom
beat them up and sexually assault them
there
that was our daily routine
hanjong's son spent three years at
brother's home
a 1987 investigation into abuse at
brother's home was quashed under
pressure from the then military
dictatorship which wanted to stifle
dissent following revelations of other
human rights abuses however these new
findings following a four-year
investigation may force lawmakers here
at the country's national assembly to
take a greater interest and pass
legislation
hanjong's son says he will be patient
if no action follows an apology then
it's just a show
for the apology to be sincere there has
to be a special law established for
compensation or no one will accept the
apology
even if they promise to make one right
now
[Music]
survivors have been filing lawsuits for
years but brother's home closed in 1987
complicating legal options
only about 600 applicants have so far
come forward for the investigation we
need to first understand exactly who the
38 thousand people were and why they
were detained and those who are verified
to have suffered could be compensated
for their damages
now han jongson continues to add details
to his reconstruction hoping it offers
more concrete testimony
if people call this art
perhaps maybe it is but i don't think
it's art
but if that system can be seen with the
eyes
then perhaps people could understand
more easily and be more convinced
that inspires me to recreate what i
remember
han's sister was taking the brother's
home with him
she did not fare so well
his father was brought later both have
since lived in state psychiatric
hospitals
han jong-sun now wants only to care for
them
and for more on this i'm joined by
a writer and co-founder of the platform
korea expose that reports and stories
from the korean peninsula
the brothers home scandal isn't at all
something one associates with the modern
image of south korea that we at least
all have how well known is this in south
korea itself
well the fact that it's not so well
known outside south korea
is unfortunate because it has been an
extremely well-known story inside the
country ever since the case first
surfaced in 1987
i'm sure you know all the details of the
horrific abuse
suffered by those who
had to stay in this facility not to
mention many people who died there
and as a result um there was a great
deal of media publicity
in the 80s and even in the early 90s and
what's made the story even more shocking
in south korea is the fact that the
perpetrators of this crime
were really very lightly and the founder
of the facility
uh he even went on to
continue doing so-called charity work
after he was released from prison
and the family continues to maintain a
substantial fortune
derived from this
report
there's so many aspects to this but as
you uh correctly said the case already
had come to light in 1987. what
confronts me is that it's taken until
last month for this call for an apology
to be issued why has it taken so long
well it shows to some extent how justice
works in the south korean context
even when there are effects and there is
an investigation it does not necessarily
lead to
meaningful action or change
uh in the case of
brother's home
uh we were still looking at the tail end
of the military dictatorship in south
korea
and one that was facing
considerable pressure
from the various pro-democracy uprisings
within the country
the dictator at the time john duan was
about to lose his power
and the government was very much
invested in making sure that this new
scandal did not add to the negative
image of the government at the time
so it has been
made known that the government also
actively
attempted to conceal certain facts of
the story and also to minimize the
judicial proceedings that took place
thereafter
and of course um
it's already a long time ago 35 years
ago
and people tend to forget
and many of the victims
they suffered severe trauma and they did
not really go
make a very high profile fight
in the quest for justice
and indeed in fact uh many people credit
one particular survivor for bringing the
the matter again to the public's
attention around 2012.
uh he staged the hunger strikes he wrote
a book about his experience and slowly
the momentum started to build
but for the large majority is it safe to
say is it fair unfortunately fair to say
that
the vast majority of victims were left
to fend for themselves forgotten and
invisible
unfortunately that's precisely the case
the the victims who have come forward to
share their stories
they received absolutely no support from
the state and in fact to the contrary
many public officials attempted to
conceal the
what happened within brother's home
especially in the city of busan where
the institution was located
the officials from the city government
are known to have threatened survivors
and told them not to go public with the
story
so yes they were indeed left to fend for
themselves only this year after the
findings of the truth and reconciliation
commission started to gather
uh attention
we heard from various government
entities and also the city of busan that
they want to provide more support from
now on 35 years after the fact
we'll leave it there thanks so much for
joining us today see wong ku from
korea
expose thank you so much
you